conscious mind can learn from reading a
book so you the subconscious mind can
read a self-help book and you go wow
that sounds really great and then you
find you read the book but your life is
still the same and it turns out why and
the answer is because a subconscious
mind is more of a habit mind things that
you repeat over and over again so the
reality is if you can stay conscious be
present and when those negative thoughts
come in our head and psychologists tell
us 70% of the time the thoughts that are
going through our head are negative and
redundant so the same negative thoughts
are going through if you could stop
those thoughts if you could hear them as
they come through like oh that's not
going to work oh this will never happen
those kind of thoughts if you can hear
them and stop them consciously say no
change the belief right there just give
the more positive thing as you repeat
this more frequently and you keep
repeating it the subconscious mind
begins to learn